so what's up with the floating fetus the
black slab and the rapidly aging
astronaut in 2001 A Space Odyssey stick
around to find out
it would be an understatement to say
that Stanley Kubrick's 2001 A Space
Odyssey totally changed the game when it
was released way back in 1968 the film's
expansive narrative and surrealist
imagery launched thousands of film
studies dissertations and helped cement
Kubrick as one of the premier filmmakers
of the 20th century The Narrative of the
movie features several distinct acts the
first takes place before the dawn of
humanity and sees a community of
primates who discover a large black
rectangular monolith although the
monolith appears to be a totally
inanimate object after coming in contact
with it the primates learned that they
can use a large animal bone as a weapon
to fend off another group of primates
who have encroached on their territory
in the next section the film flashes
forward hundreds of thousands of years
into the future beyond our own time a
group of officials on a human moon base
are investigating a series of
abnormalities and discover a similar
monolith buried in a lunar crater nearby
the last section of the film settled
little over a year in the future centers
on a spaceship on a mission to Jupiter
it's this section that brings 2001 A
Space Odyssey to its famously confusing
end
we're introduced to the crew on a
mission to Jupiter most of whom are in
cryosleep with the exception of Dr David
Bowman and Dr Frank Poole there is one
other active crew member aboard the
discovery one how a computer that
controls the functions of the ship and
communicates with a monotone human male
voice during the mission Bowman and pool
become alarmed when they catch how
seemingly lying to them about a
mechanical problem with one of the
antennas on the outside of the vessel
however with no other recourse pool
exits the ship to investigate the issue
he learns the hard way that he was
correct to be suspicious of how who
sabotages pool's equipment killing him
and leaving him floating in space Bowman
exits the ship to try and save pool but
it's too late not only has Hal
deactivated the life support systems for
the crew members who were still in
cryosleep killing them all but he also
refuses to let Bowman back onto the ship
this is a shocking and terrifying
development for a number of reasons
perhaps the most cogent of them being
that how now like the bone used by the
primates in the first section of the
movie is meant to be a tool for Humanity
but it appears that Hal has a mission of
its own when Bowman tries to reboard the
ship Hal coldly informs him
this mission is too important for me to
allow you to jeopardize it
Bowman manages to make his way back into
the ship and begins to manually shut
down how while he does so the computer
pleads with him to stop promising to
stop sabotaging Bowman and repeatedly
saying
I'm afraid today
but Bowman ignores it when the computer
is fully deactivated a video suddenly
begins to play in it a man sitting at a
desk declares that the video was
recorded before the mission began but
his so top secret that only Hal was made
aware of it it seems that shutting down
Hal caused the video to autoplay even
though it was clearly meant to be played
when the crew reached their destination
in Jupiter's orbit and had all been
woken up the man in the video then
reveals the true nature of Discovery
one's mission to investigate the first
sign of intelligent life in outer space
it was a strong radio emission aimed at
Jupiter coming from the monolith
the four million year old black monolith
has remained completely inert its origin
and purpose still a total mystery
what does Mission Control hope to find
when the ship reaches Jupiter and does
the existence of this video a profound
piece of existential knowledge uploaded
into Hal's Mainframe have anything to do
with the computer's sudden sentience
unfortunately for Bowman he doesn't have
time to piece that puzzle together as
Discovery 1 is arriving in Jupiter's
orbit and things are about to get weird
as the discovery 1 approaches Jupiter it
encounters one of the monoliths orbiting
the planet and then Bowman is pulled
into a slipstream of psychedelic colors
for an extended sequence when it ends
he's no longer on the spaceship and is
instead in a classically ornate bedroom
suite with futuristic lighted floor
tiles he has also aged considerably a
fact that startles him when he walks
into the bathroom and sees himself in
the mirror while in the bathroom he
looks through a doorway back into the
bedroom where he now sees a man sitting
at a table eating dinner and wearing a
black rope the man turns around and
reveals that he is Bowman this Bowman
gets up from the table and walks to the
bathroom to look around as though he
heard something
when he returns to the table he knocks
over a glass when he turns to pick it up
there's now an even older version of
Bowman on the bed in the room one that
is clearly near death the older Bowman
points to the end of his bed and the
camera cuts to reveal one of the black
monoliths floating in front of him when
the camera Cuts back to Bowman he has
transformed into a fetus suspended in a
glowing call over the bed we then see
the fetus floating in space and
observing Earth with a curious look at
its eyes there are lots of theories and
interpretations of 2001 A Space
odyssey's ending ultimately however it's
clearly a movie that is meant to be
thought about discussed and watched from
different points of view that being said
there is some obvious threads of
connection between the seemingly
separate elements of the film that help
explain what it's all about Mankind's
harnessing of technology is one of the
clear themes of the movie The Moment the
primates start viewing the bone as a
tool can be seen as a direct precursor
to the later sections of the movie that
depict man in an advanced Space Age
although these advancements are exciting
they also bring with them serious
existential conundrums such as the
beginning of weaponized Warfare the
discovery of the alien monolith on the
moon and the emerging sentience of how
I know I've never completely freed
myself of the suspicion
that there are some extremely odd things
about this mission
in perhaps Bowman's rapid aging at the
end of the film is representative of the
price Humanity pays for these
advancements he is Disturbed each time
an older version of himself is revealed
until he's transformed into a fetus and
exists with Tranquility this could be
read either as his regression back to a
state of blissful ignorance similar to
the primates before they encounter the
monolith or Evolution into some new
state of technological primitivism after
all the fetus appears to be in some kind
of glowing orb and floats through space
where it is able to gain a simple yet
powerful existential perspective a view
of the Earth from space where does that
lead the monolith is it a literal piece
of alien technology that is influencing
Humanity's Evolution or merely symbolic
of the terrifyingly inscrutable path our
technological advancements have put us
on ultimately that is one of those
questions each viewer will have to
answer for themselves
foreign